Christian is beside me stretched out on
a Sun lounge my husband my hot beautiful
husband shirtless and in cutoff jeans is
reading a book predicting the collapse
of the Western banking system I flush I
didn't get much sleep last night
me neither he grins puts down his
blackberry and stands his shorts fall a
little and hang in that way so his swim
trunks are visible beneath mr. grey will
see you now
[Music]
fifty Shades freed is a 2008 teen film
directed by James Foley written by Nell
Leonard adapted from the 2012 novel of
the same name written by television
executive Erica Mitchell under the pen
name Yale James originally published
online is Twilight fan fiction between
August 2010 and May 2011 under the title
master of the universe two freed is
unique in the series in that it is the
only chunk of the trilogy that was
somewhat conceived as a finite story
with publication in mind by January of
2011 about halfway through as for the
universe 2's writing Mitchell had
reached an agreement with Australian
publisher the writers coffee shop and
the process of editing master of the
universe part 1 into 50 shades of grey
and fifty shades darker had begun this
would be publicly announced at the end
of the March fifth installment of master
of the universe - in conjunction with
the online version of more or less
everything up to that point being pulled
from fanfiction.net and fifty shades com
I have some exciting news well exciting
for me I've been given the opportunity
to publish this beast by T WCS so I am
going ahead and doing that the first
book yes there's more than one it's so
long as you know will be out at the end
of May I have pulled everything except
the last few chapters of Mo to you - I
know a great deal if you will be
delighted for me and some less so you
must tell me what you want if you are
still speaking to me I was actually able
to find a copy of master of the universe
- with the blog notes still intact which
makes for a fascinating read injecting
the content
of public performance back into the text
like it's wild to see that at the exact
moment publication was assured every
outstanding plot thread is either
dropped or resolved the entire main plot
is resolved in the next chapter after
the announcement and the three after
that are mostly various characters
explaining things to Bella and
backfilling the majority of the plot
holes and you'll be happy to know that
the legacy of Fifty Shades freed as a
hastily written fillin has been
preserved in the film version sadly they
didn't preserve the parts where the
American characters talked like a
middle-aged English woman he smirks eat
he orders you didn't eat yesterday Oh
bossy 50 that's because you were being
an arse mrs. Jones dropped something
that clatters into the sink making me
jump Christian seems oblivious to the
noise ignoring her he stares at me and
passively arse or not eat his tone is
serious no arguing with him now the main
history of Fifty Shades that I relayed
in the first video focused entirely on
the pedigree of the film's the chain of
adaptation but let's take a minute to
talk about the parallel history to that
in early 2012 as the deal with vintage
was materializing Mitchell tried to
erase the history of Fifty Shades from
the internet the remaining content on
Fifty Shades com was deleted and
replaced with a stock author bio light
blog takedown notifications were issued
to various blogs that had syndicated the
fanfic and Erica's lawyers contacted the
Internet Archive and had both Fifty
Shades calm and the relevant pages on
fanfiction.net removed from the archive
listing not only did this eliminate the
most obvious copies of the fik but
effectively wiped out a tremendous
amount of the parallel discussions that
are now left to only be relayed by word
of mouth assembling the timeline of
basic events like when was the first
chapter posted fanfiction.net or when
were the books first published was
surprisingly difficult for something
that happened only eight years ago the
information is crumbling some lost to
digital decay and some to deliberate
abuse
the history of Fifty Shades has
effectively become folklore and folklore
is a delicate thing in interviews
following publication Mitchell would
tell a few different variant stories
about the origin of Fifty Shades
generally downplaying or outright
denying the fanfiction origins of the
story even up through 2017 the go-to
narrative was this muddled sort of half
truth about how she wrote a Twilight fan
fiction and then wrote another story
that would go on to inspire Fifty Shades
of Grey I read about something called
fan fiction I didn't know what fan
fiction was I thought was interesting
and I looked up and and I decided to
have a go myself or so I wrote I wrote a
novel a 70,000 word novel in three weeks
and while I was doing that I had the
idea for what became Fifty Shades now
it's sort of a weird half truth because
there is another fanfic before Fifty
Shades of Grey before master of the
universe there was safe haven by snow
Queens ice dragon Edward Cullen is
filming his new movie in Las Vegas
his only solace is Bella who lives and
works in the luxury hotel he is staying
but is she all she seems explicit adult
content it's not entirely clear which
strictly came first but safe haven was
the first fanfiction posted to
fanfiction.net under the handle snow
Queens ice dragon and it is functionally
a 143 page prototype of master of the
universe told from Edwards perspective
the obsession with Audi the classical
music the way Bella is a virgin who has
never so much has had an impure thought
before Edward comes along the pervasive
misogyny and the fact that it's really
just a loose retelling of Twilight
hitting most of the same major plot
beats it's revealing because it sets out
patterns and Mitchell's writing that can
be seen repeating throughout the rest of
her work elements that remain fixed in
place even after edits or adaptations
the critical one being this anna is not
the self-insert of Fifty Shades
Christian is this is part of why I find
safe haven fascinating
the first fanfic wasn't Bella's point of
view it was Edwards and Edie
that is controlling demanding petty and
easily angered through adaptation
through mutation from Edward to
Christian these are the personality
traits that stay intact the screenwriter
is replaced and given a mandate to
preserve the accuracy of the books and
what's the thing that survives the
process dumb ass arguments about an
email address where Christian uses his
power to get pointless concessions out
of people in a way that improves nothing
but makes him happy because now people
are doing his bidding I tried to
emailing you it bounced we talked a
bunch in the last video about how Erica
pretty much hijacked the production but
I didn't really talk about how the
leverage that she kept using on the set
of the first film was that if any change
displeased her too much she would
withdraw support and tell all her fans
to boycott the movie which in the
context of a film like Fifty Shades is
pretty much death it's the kind of movie
that relies very heavily on fans to be
the backbone to be the word of mouth
more than on a general audience just
going to see it because it looks cool
marketing wise it was 100% banking on
being the movie version of a cultural
phenomenon as opposed to the adaptation
of a good story with this in mind it
ends up being really fascinating when
you watch the behind the scenes extras
for darker and the selling point of the
new writer and director now Leonard and
James Foley is they get along with Erica
he's incredibly experienced and he has a
has a very impressive roster of great
films under him and we met and we just
hit it off and now who's actually
Erica's husband did the adaptation which
I thought was a good thing for us as
producers because he lived with these
books in the process of these books
being written he did a really fantastic
job of boiling everything down so that
we got all the main set pieces
fan moments that would be expected eeep
kind of would often did his thing and
then he'd bring me a draft said what do
you think can I go this this this and
we're still speaking to each other so I
think that's probably a good thing and
just from watching the on set
interactions and all this material and
how Eric has pretty much just directing
the movie it's obvious that Mitchell
threatened Universal that she would take
her ball and go home so they found her a
proxy writer in her husband and a proxy
director in James Foley it's also
fascinating how Gray's behind the scenes
stuff spends a lot of time talking with
Johnson and Dornan about the sex scenes
and both of them relay at length how
much trust do they put in director Sam
taylor-johnson how much work she put
into helping them find a headspace they
could be in and work in and then for the
second and third movies they're out on
the press junket talking about doing
whiskey shots to get through the sex
scenes you guys have a pregame ritual
before these scenes on the lighter side
of that subject I'm pretty sure I can
identify the first scene where Dakota
Johnson was drinking to get through the
day and it's the topless boat scene from
darker the tell to me is that Dakota
Johnson just seems kind of drunk so one
of the things that really stood out to
me as I was getting into all of this as
I was researching and assembling this
whole long project was that with every
pass I made over the movies the
differences became more and more clear
the level of craft put into the smaller
things became more and more identifiable
this is how we first see him very
structured very businesslike the next he
takes around a small coffee date it's
still guarded with the vest protecting
the heart area but it's a little more
open and trying to be more of a regular
guy it's also worn with
blue jeans it's open it's one level it's
a different color and has the little
flare of a pocket square and so in
subtle ways we find him opening up and
wrapping his mind around becoming part
of her life Erika was very cleaned up
movies two and three should stick as
closely as possible to the books until
the the sense of the books into the
sense of the story freed is basically a
low-budget James Bond knockoff like if
instead of having a whole bunch of wild
gadgets a car chase a boat chase and a
fight on a helicopter there was instead
a gadget a car going over the speed
limit a boat and a fight anyway the
movie opens with a wedding montage and
already I want to stop and talk about
the sickly green undertone that's being
grated into this scene so green is very
common in nature but it's rare for the
ambient light to be green green ambience
is unnatural and off-putting so using
green as an undertone or even as an
overtone is in cinematic language
shorthand for a state that is unnatural
disconcerting or wrong it's why the
matrix is tinted green why the office in
Joe versus the volcano is green and why
the first Twilight movie is pretty much
entirely green until Bela decides to
stay in Forks also the fact that it is
unnatural makes it a really obvious tell
if you're watching a movie and the
lighting looks tinted green it's because
someone was mucking with it it didn't
just happen to look like that given that
freed is going to be more of a thriller
it makes sense that we're going to see
green used as an undertone and it makes
sense that it would appear early in the
film to set the mood it makes sense when
Jack Hyde is breaking into grey
Enterprise Holdings incorporated to
plant a fire bomb in the server room but
it doesn't make sense for it to be used
in a wedding scene when that wedding is
supposed to be fairytale beautiful when
this is supposed to be the emotional
high before anything has had a chance to
spoil it and as a visual shorthand it's
use is really inconsistent some relevant
scenes have it some don't and there's
nowhere else in the movie
where it's as pervasive as it is in the
wedding
all right so we're 30 seconds into the
film and I've already gone on for a
minute about color cool anyway the rest
of the title montage is all honeymoon
stuff in Paris and things finally settle
on the beach with Anna asking Christian
to apply more sunscreen to my
disappointment they decided to skip on
the literal adaptation of Christian Grey
image-conscious billionaire lounging at
the beach in cutoff jeans over swim
trunks ladies but Christian leaves Anna
to have a swim and Anna removes the rest
of her top anyway
cutting away from that a mysterious
stranger gets into Christians office
tower changes into a disguise hacks the
electronic lock on the server room and
then plants a bomb wait for it Christian
and Hannah argue again about Anna taking
her top off and Christian finally
reminds her that there might be
paparazzi around continuing the fine
tradition of Christian always being
justified for pushing Anna around see
it's just like when he pulled her out of
the way of the bike then the argument
ends and they go back to the boat and
have sex Christian's assistant Roz calls
and informs them that the bomb did
indeed finally go off it totally
exploded you know over there off screen
just just made a real mess of things
totally fried the server's lots of
damage really really expensive damage
just over just you know over over there
anyway it's Jack Hyde that's jack
oh and also the helicopter crash was
totally sabotage and that was also Jack
Hyde I got a report from the FAA they
don't think that the helicopter crash
was an accident they said it looks like
sabotage Jack Hyde fiction editor
sabotage Christians helicopter the day
after Jack Hyde fiction editor was fired
from his job as fiction editor Jack Hyde
fiction editor sabotage the helicopter
Anna and Christian cut their honeymoon
short go home meet the new security
guards Christian is hired and get into a
petty argument about having children
starting one of the major threats for
the movie don't worry
it gets worse Anna goes to work where
she finds out that while she was gone on
her honeymoon her temporary promotion
has been made permanent and the office
was renovated and liz is pretty
obviously resentful of the whole
situation I mean yeah by the way liz is
the head of human resources at si P who
you might remember from the last movie
as the woman who clearly knew Jack was
bad news but still encouraged Anna to
spend time with him in a social capacity
and as assistant Hanna comes in and the
two talk about changing Anna's email
address from Anastasia Steele to
Anastasia gray and Anna just says you
know what leave it for now
the scene wraps up in cuts to Anna
taking a meeting with her biggest client
voice Fox when Christian comes storming
into the office demands to speak with
Anna immediately insinuates that she's
cheating with her client then throws a
fit because he tried to send an email to
Anastasia gray at publishing company
comm and it bounced I try to emailing
you it bounced there's no Anastasia grey
at s IP and we're going to talk about
lighting now this whole point is
incredibly petty but the fact that they
didn't realize the set between the two
scenes is what really elevates it to
comedy for me it isn't just later the
same day it's basically immediately Anna
goes to work the Sun streaming through
her windows and before she's even taken
a coffee break
Christian is standing in her office
demanding to know if their marriage is a
sham because she has been back to work
for 45 minutes already and hasn't yet
changed her email address to this
compelling argument Anna caves pretty
much instantly because she has at this
point more or less accepted that her
life largely consists of managing
Christians emotions for him and his face
lights up with just the most punchable
grin just your just a reminder this
isn't even an argument about her
changing her legal name it's purely
about her changing her professional name
and her email address also it will never
come up again there is no future
complication as a result of changing
email addresses and it doesn't
even become petty ammunition in a future
argument anna says she'll think about it
Christians like yay I believe my wife
into giving me a petty win and just like
the bathing suit it's never mentioned
again after work
Christian drives Anna out to the country
and surprises her with a house I didn't
even mention this in the previous movie
but when Christian and Anna spent a day
on his boat Anna saw this house on the
shore and was like that's a nice house I
love that house and now Christian is
like hey I bought you this house that
you like and then Christians architect
comes in and is like cool so we're going
to bulldoze the house and Christian is
like yes let's bulldoze the house that I
bought for my wife because she said that
she loves the house if that sounds like
bizarro whiplash that's because it's set
up for Anna's transformation into a
wealth monster because the architect Jia
is a blonde and as we've discussed
blondes and Fifty Shades are all home
wreckers and temptresses so Anna dresses
her down for the vicarious enjoyment of
Erica Mitchell who hates women in
general and blondes in specific oh and
this is a good place for a reminder that
in the logic of the story
Christian hired gia specifically because
she's a blonde so that she wouldn't
remind him of his dead mother who he
refers to as the crack [ __ ] and thus he
wouldn't feel compelled to beat her
sexually in an act of displaced revenge
anyway Christian lets Anna drive home
and they get in a car chase and that
have sex in a parking lot back home
their security tells them the driver
that was chasing them is a woman then
Anna finds Leila's gun still loaded in
Christians desk drawer and he promises
to get rid of it a whole bunch of
nothing happens until Anna goes out with
Kate for drinks even though Christian
told her to go straight home and then
Anna gets home and Jack Hyde who has
broken into their apartment attacks her
with a kitchen knife and tries to kidnap
her but he's taken down by her new
security guards better restrain him
we do find something all right that that
lines kind of funny like it's funny on
purpose I like that line I like that
line it's funny on purpose also because
of this detail is hilarious I want to
point out that in the book this doesn't
happen Jack doesn't take Anna captive at
knifepoint instead Anna gets home from
the bar and the action is already
resolved Jack broke in while she was
gone and her security team has already
incapacitated him everything exciting
already happened off screen see that's
what happens when you don't actually
edit your fanfic before publishing it as
a novel Anna is talking with the police
who tell her that in Jack's stolen van
they found a note saying you owe me a
life and assure her that he's definitely
not going to get out all right then
there's three scenes where nothing
really happens but Christian isn't happy
then Anna gets home from work and
Christian takes her into the playroom
where he tortures her with orgasm denial
in revenge for saying she would go home
but then going out drinking with Kate
and it escalates to the point that Anna
needs to use her safe word now okay
there is a bit to unravel here first I'm
going to refer back to what I said in
the first part of this series it's OK
from a narrative perspective if
Christian is a dick it's just that the
conflict that arises out of it needs to
go somewhere the issue is that despite
the fact that Anna is the one who is
being wronged here the scene still
pivots to be about Christians man pain
and explain why it is that he just can't
stop abusing her and with that violation
of trust out of the way the movie comes
to a standstill for 15 minutes while
Anna in the gang piss off to Aspen for
the weekend
wait wait the bikini the email address
the attempted punishing her for going
out with Kate despite the fact that she
was attacked at knifepoint less than 24
hours earlier it it's almost like
there's a pattern of Christian violating
Anna's boundaries and then giving her
extravagant gifts and/or sex in lieu of
apologizing when they get back detective
Clark tells Anna that Jack Hyde the man
who was caught on camera planting a bomb
stole a vehicle and attempt
to kidnap Ana at knifepoint is probably
going to get bail because he's saying
that she came on to him first and he
totally didn't try to molest her
so extenuating circumstances Ana goes to
the courthouse for his bail hearing and
sure enough he gets bail though the
judge sets bail at half a million
dollars because it's his first offense
or well his first slate of offenses
including criminal arson grand theft
auto and attempted kidnapping but who's
keeping count Ana immediately runs to
the bathroom and throws up then hard cut
to the doctor's office where Ana's
gynecologist tells her that whoopsie
doodles she's pregnant because she
hasn't taken her birth control since the
end of the last movie at dinner anna
tells christian that she's pregnant and
christian is like that's bad I don't
want a baby right now and Ana's like I
know it's bad I don't want a baby right
now either
and even though that makes it sound like
the two of them are totally on the same
page visa Vee this pregnancy they just
yell at each other instead Christian
storms off eventually coming home in the
middle of the night piss-drunk where he
slurs about his fear that Ana will
choose the baby over him as Ana is
putting his stuff away he gets a text
from Elena saying good to see you
tonight
I'm here for you anytime which sets ana
off so she goes and sleeps in the
playroom the next morning Christian is
busy organizing the help into a search
and rescue party when Ana comes
downstairs this begins a prolonged
argument between the two where Ana is
naked for most of its like if it's just
an entire scene of dialogue and
throughout Ana is just naked it's nudity
that's pointless to the point it's
honestly kind of surreal alright I I
don't know how to segue this because
just saying it out loud makes it sound
somehow even more abrupt than it
actually is but like an hour later and
it gets a phone call from Mia except
it's Jack Hyde and he wants five million
dollars in ransom in two hours or he's
going to kill Mia so so I I don't I
don't know what Jack's exit strategy is
here he's out on bail for a
bunch of really serious crimes and Anna
knows exactly who he is so it's not like
he's some anonymous dude who can grab a
duffel bag full of money and just
disappear and he doesn't know this but
Christian doesn't actually like his
family all that much so killing Mia
would maybe make Christian a bit sad but
mostly it's just going to add murder to
Jack's already substantial list of
crimes that he's already definitely
going to prison for I don't know we'll
talk more about Jack's plan later in the
meantime Anna goes home changes into her
teenage runaway outfit gets a duffel bag
the checkbook and grabs Leila's gun
which Christian had promised to get rid
of several weeks ago hey isn't it weird
how whenever Anna breaks tiny
inconsequential promises like I'll come
straight home after work or I won't take
my top off on a topless beach its deemed
worthy of derision and punishment but
when Christian breaks his promise to get
rid of a loaded handgun that he keeps in
an unlocked drawer in their home it's
fine because it totally turned out Anna
needed a loaded handgun anyway now that
she's armed and dangerous
she gives Sawyer the slip and takes off
for the bank at the bank Anna dressed in
a hoodie and clearly in a hurry asked to
withdraw five million dollars in cash
from the joint account banks don't carry
that much cash on hand by the way but
just accept it or we'll be here all day
the bank manager Troy Whalen calls
Christian to confirm the transaction and
Christian asks to speak to Anna in
private after their conversation a
sobbing Anna gives the phone back and
Christian tells Waylon to give her the
money despite this being a situation
built entirely out of red flags Waylon
gives her the cash and his phone and
helps her take the money out the back
door of the bank and load it into an SUV
being driven by a person who looks like
they're trying to look shady oh and the
driver is Liz you know the head of human
resources at si P she's the one who got
into the high-speed car chase through
Seattle so Christian has figured out
that something's up and that me is
missing so he calls the cops and he's
tracking Anna cellphone which she
hid in the bag of money so everyone's
converging on the spot where Jack has
Mia tied up
Jack beats Anna up and kicks her in the
stomach so oh no pregnant then Anna
shoots Jack and the police arrive and
that's it
the entire standoff resolves in about 45
seconds from there it's just a slow roll
downhill to the end Christian wants a
baby now and the baby's okay and here's
all the Jack hides motivations and stuff
sort of I guess
Christian is shocked because he realizes
the only substantial difference between
him and being a pervert middle manager
is that he started off with millions of
dollars and turned it into billions but
this rare moment of accurate self
assessment is undercut by Anna
disagreeing if I'd been left in the
system who knows how I would have turned
out man of honour and you treat people
well i Karev you're showing plenty as it
is I get off and punishing women women
who look like you thank you mother
I tried emailing you it bounced there's
no Anastasia grey @s IP and you treat
people well turns out Jack and Christian
were in the same foster home in Detroit
and Jack remembers and resents Christian
and and we'll talk about this in a bit
we're almost on the movie Anna and
Christian visit the grave of Christians
birth mother and he doesn't once call
heard the crack [ __ ] the crack [ __ ]
used to let me play with her hair I
think I don't know if it's a memory or a
dream whoa his birth mom there's a
montage of all the highlights from the
trilogy which is weird because it really
just calls attention to the fact that
nothing has really happened then the
movie fake ends with Anna setting up the
playroom and it's the first time in the
movies that Christians Rati Dom jeans
have gotten any explicit attention
rather than just being an environmental
detail so this loving close-up of Anna
reverently laying them out on the bed is
kind of comical Christian comes in and
remarks that Anna is topping from the
bottom a line that we're going to be
talking about a lot in a bit and fade to
black for a few credits before an
epilogue where everyone's happy and rich
and Anna's pregnant with their second
kid Vee
end all right get a drink we'll be right
back this episode was brought to you by
tap water mm-hmm good old municipal tap
water this is by far the most literal
adaptation of the three Noda helped by
master of the universe to being somewhat
more self-contained and less of a
sprawling catastrophe there's a bunch of
stuff but the main one that I really
want to talk about is that last line
because I've been wanting to talk about
it
since we started it's this line from
Christian to Anna I believe you're
topping from the bottom
flashback time mitchell also has an
awkward habit of juxtaposing erotic
imagery with infantile izing internal
commentary from anastasia anna is
seemingly perpetually confused by the
world around her and naive to the point
of farce a thread that persists all the
way to the very end of the trilogy you
know you're topping from the bottom he
murmurs against my lips what I don't
understand what he's talking about if
you've been following along with the
movies and you still find these
characters to be insufferable and
frustrating that's fair
but I promise you it doesn't hold a
candle to the books Mitchell as a writer
is seemingly incapable of ever changing
characterization all the way up to the
final pages of the book Anna is still
utterly oblivious to the world that she
has gotten herself into so this change
having anna implicitly acknowledged that
she is in fact the one who's really in
control here I like it
I wish it were in a better movie one of
my favorite changes from the book mostly
because of how it contrasts the original
has to be the ending with Christians
mom's gravestone like this is such a
natural end point for Christian as a
character the book is even called
Fifty Shades freed Christian is Fifty
Shades Anna calls him 50 constantly in
her inner monologue so the title of the
book is Christian Grey freed it is the
book where ostensibly Christian finally
gets over his myriad problems and can
normal except he doesn't okay so in
darker at the midpoint of the book
remember Christian has a major
miraculous breakthrough where he no
longer feels compelled to take out his
psycho sexual hang-ups on Anna it at
least as far as physical violence is
concerned and he lets Anna touch him so
after that the big hang-ups would be his
need for petty control and his fear of
parenthood which is tied in with his
resentment of his mother alright in this
book he resolves one of these which is
that he gets over his very specific
hang-ups about being afraid the baby
will split and his attention and she
won't be able to vote all her energy to
managing his emotions anymore but he's
still petty and controlling just look at
the whole email argument and the
sunbathing argument and the went out
drinking with Kate argument
none of that comes back none of it is
resolved and Christian never lets go of
that problem but it's the other one
that's just baffling the first time
Christian refers to his mother in Fifty
Shades of Grey he calls her a crack
[ __ ] and the last time he refers to her
in Fifty Shades freed he calls her the
crack [ __ ] how do you feel about that I
whisper he frowns about having no living
relatives [ __ ] that they were anything
like the crack [ __ ] he shakes his head
and discussed so why is it that the film
version is able to see such an obvious
bit of closure where the originals
weren't the answer is that Erica
Mitchell just doesn't think that there's
anything wrong with this framing since
Anna also refers to Christians mother as
the crack [ __ ] this is confusing
I'm his wife not as submissive not some
company he's acquired I'm not the crack
[ __ ] who was his mother change of pace
let's disassemble Jack's plot in its
entirety and for that we're going to go
all the way back to childhood Jack Hyde
spends his youth in the foster care
system of Michigan when he is 8 or 9
Christian is put into the same home as
him for two months at some point Jack is
adopted or simply ages out but either
way he is able to attend Princeton
graduate and move out to Seattle where
he gets a job as the fiction
editor at a successful boutique
publisher he also becomes a sex pervert
and rapist to molest his coworkers and
keeps a log of sex tapes as leverage
then one day he hires a new assistant
named Anastasia Steele at the end of her
first week on the job they go out to a
bar where Jack meets her boyfriend
Christian Grey which starts some wheels
spinning in Jack's head the next night
he infiltrates an exclusive charity
dinner and auction in order to creep on
Christian the following Tuesday Jack
pins Anastasia against the door of his
office and gropes her then gets kneading
the balls and beat up by her boyfriend
security guard
later that evening he's fired because
Christian has all but officially bought
the company two days later he sabotages
Christians helicopter Charlie Tango
causing it to crash in the forest near
Mount st. Helens but Christian survives
the next night Jack watches them
celebrate Christian's birthday from
across the lake at their home two months
later he breaks into Christian Grey's
offices and hacks into Gray's personal
files before firebombing the servers he
then contacts his former coworker Liz
and uses the threat of releasing their
sex tape to have her get into a car
chase with Christian and Anna from the
countryside into downtown Seattle what
the point of that was remains unknown
because Anna manages to shake her off in
traffic a week and a half after the
bombing he steals an elevator
maintenance van outfits it with fake
license plates and uses the van and I
guess the tools in it to gain access to
the elevator at escala which gives him
access to the apartment where he hides
in the closet with a kitchen knife until
Anna comes home he then tries to kidnap
and at knife point but is incapacitated
by her personal security and arrested by
police who find a note in the van that
says you owe me a life a few weeks later
he is granted bail set at $500,000 which
he pays the next day jack is released
from custody and with the help of Liz
immediately kidnaps Christian's sister
Mia and tries to ransom her for five
million dollars but is thwarted when
Hannah shoots him in the leg with a gun
and also the cops arrive and arrest him
so it's maybe a little weird and
pointless to interrogate the inner life
of a one-dimensional character though
it's just as weird that Jack starts as
Anna's antagonist but we're assured that
no he actually already hated Christian
before Christian got him fired and
everything with Anna is basically pure
coincidence this is why the baby
plotline feels so weird it doesn't
really matter because Anna doesn't
really want anything the last thing she
wanted was a career of her own so
Christian bought her a publishing
company since then she's pretty much
been on autopilot part of what makes a
thriller great is watching a convoluted
plan come together a good thriller has a
plan that's complicated and maybe even a
little bit wacky but there's this deep
satisfaction from watching it all fall
into place
this is not that Jack's scheme is less
of a plan and more of a series of
disconnected twists that made good
cliffhangers for a serial fan fiction
that was being written with an end goal
but no plan
the longer you think about it the worse
it gets I mean for one all the
individual parts are just absurd on
their own merits a woman who works in
human resources gets into a high-speed
chase through traffic for no discernible
reason a fiction editor sabotages a
private helicopter and firebombs a
server after stealing personal files
that have no purpose or value in their
own right now if you want to talk about
one of the clearest examples of backfill
where a writer has addressed a problem
in their writing not by going back and
making changes to the earlier parts of
the text but by explaining things after
the fact
We Need to Talk About link the ultimate
antagonist of the Fifty Shades book the
puppet master at the middle of it all is
a man named link or mr. Lincoln he's
only mentioned in the books about five
times total depending on how you count
and even the fan wiki considers him so
superfluous to the story
that he isn't even given an entry in the
list of minor characters an added scene
at the end of the Unrated cut of the
film refers to him as
on Lincoln so the movies eventually gave
him a first name but he's not in the
theatrical cut at all
even in the extended version he's only
in two scenes and freed one where he's
introduced and one where he's arrested
and you know what I'm I'm hard pressed
to decide which is worse storytelling
having an epilogue that amounts to oh
yeah this guy this guy here he totally
did it he did it all because reasons and
also he did it by funding this other guy
who wanted to destroy Christians life
for completely unrelated reasons or
having an epilogue that leaves you with
the absurd conclusion that a fiction
editor would have the means skill and
opportunity to sabotage a helicopter in
an incredibly precise way such that it
would still work but would fail after
several hours of flight infiltrate the
high security areas of an office tower
belonging to a notoriously paranoid
billionaire to plant a James Bond style
bomb steal a car forge a fake license
plate break into the home of a fir
mentioned billionaire at a point when he
has explicitly raised security and just
pay half a million dollars in bail and
if you think I'm being a little thin
with motivation here this is about all
that exists basically link found out
about Christians relationship with Elena
and then they got a divorce but also he
was abusing her so they were probably
going to get a divorce anyway oh look
there's that thread again where people
become Dom's because of unresolved
trauma but that's it that's the sum
total of link as he appears in both book
and film and again the only reason that
the books have a secret puppet master
villain in the first place is because
Mitchell needed to explain how Jack
suddenly had the resources to both get
and pay bail when he's being charged
with arson grand theft auto
Breaking and Entering and attempted
kidnapping the funny thing is that this
was really easy to fix just make a Lena
the actual villain from a filmmaking
perspective this movie just makes the
previous movie all the more confusing
because it's not like they were adapting
Fifty Shades
darker before Fifty Shades freed was
written the books were done you could
read the whole thing and know how it
ends and work towards a conclusion
instead of ending fifty shades darker on
the same abrupt I have no idea where I'm
going with this note that Mitchell did
when she finished master of the universe
in 2010 I know I don't know why they
didn't make that change why they decided
to try and do a literal adaptation and
then cut it for something just as bad
the only answer I can posit is that
reading the books the books are very
defensive of Elena so keep in mind that
Christians framing of problems and
conflicts is almost always taken as true
or superior or justified Christian
consistently goes to bat for Elena
whenever Anna does get to voice some
criticism of her Christian always
defends Elena and the final landing
point in the book is Christian saying
that maybe a sexual relationship between
a middle-aged woman and a fifteen year
old boy isn't a great idea but they were
both wrong and they'd still be friends
but Anna doesn't like Elena so he's
willing to let that friendship go it's
messed up
in conclusion Fifty Shades of Grey is a
land of contrasts or as the natives call
it maze it's it's corny is what I'm
saying the books are and remain a
contentious piece of literature for the
way they muddy the line between kink and
abuse replicating and reinforcing
abusive and potentially deadly
relationship dynamics the movies are a
nominal thematic improvement but despite
good changes to characterization and
some light plot restructuring the movies
ultimately hue too close to the books
and in turn inherit almost all the
original structural problems while the
first movie shows a surprising amount of
creative talent and effort the second
and third are notably devoid of creative
energy with long stretches where the
lead actors seem irritated to still be
there anyway the movie denham us with a
montage which is up there with a dance
number in the pantheon of we didn't know
quite how to end this one
but really the
thing is The Twilight Saga Breaking Dawn
Part 2 ended with a little musical
montage so Fifty Shades has to end with
a musical montage to quote fellow critic
Jenny Nicholson at least in Twilight
those movies escalated to an insane
degree so it was like look how far
they've come in this one they're just
married now
it's the same but you know what I'm
going to disagree with that look at how
far they come look at how far we've all
come you know you're topping from the
bottom he murmurs against my lips
[Music]
understand what is talking
she's the Eurocopter easy one
[Music]
do you feel now there is one part of the
whole fanfiction in books that I've only
incidentally mentioned up to this point
and that's the straight ripoff of
Midnight's son which was the version of
Twilight told from Edwards perspective
that Stephenie Meyer scrapped in 2008
after some test chapters were leaked to
the Internet during the writing of
master of the universe Mitchell included
several side chapters as bonus content
on her website including a few that were
just parallels of existing chapters told
from Edwards point of view one of these
was included at the end of Fifty Shades
freed and is basically chapters two and
three of Fifty Shades of Grey but from
Christians perspective in June 2015 grey
Fifty Shades of Grey from Christians
perspective was released now this
actually poses an interesting
opportunity especially since the book
was being developed in parallel to the
first film and released only a few
months afterwards conceptually retelling
the story from Christians point of view
provides an opportunity to address and
incorporate criticisms maybe even going
as far as straight-up retconning
elements that didn't work most
interestingly since it is now Christian
doing the telling is potentially a
chance to recharacterize Christian via
his internal monologue maybe bring him
more in line with Jamie Dornan
performance of the character rather than
how the character would appear from a
strict reading of the originals it's
essentially a third chance to adapt her
own story I mean surely it would be
comical if a movie came out and was
commended for trying to make the abusive
monster of Christian Grey into someone
at least conceptually likable and then
the next book just doubled down on all
of Christians worst behaviors indicating
not just compulsion in his actions but
malice and forethought right clearly
sensibly Erica Mitchell is going to
seize this opportunity to paint a
picture of a character who is in
conflict with his own evil and isn't
just an abuser and rapist I'm not
knowledgeable Anastasia I just know what
I like and I like you some more I nod
towards the bottle on the table please
if
the champagne and refill her cup she
regards me suspiciously
she knows I'm plying her with alcohol
nope
[Music]
baby it's going to take more than a
malfunction in 1/35 to keep me away from
you
[Music]
very easy
you
[Music]